and of course Paul Felder is coming in
now and the Tefft all the Irish dragon
he's fighting it to UFC 223 this
Saturday at the Barclays and I is
fighting al Iaquinta how you doing buddy
I'll let you sit down first before I
would say hello too soon I'm nervous and
excited I do I'm always happy to see
people like both of us drinking water
huh yeah lots of I got a whole gallon of
it Wow only one today why you came out
so much this to make you pick on with
the 8 ounce yeah we uh we drink about
two gallons for I'm doing it for about
eight eight days now so it's a swelling
today yeah to two gallons a day plus my
coffees and you know little things like
that so what does that do for you
it's a water load right so it kind of
tricks your body into thinking it's
almost overly hydrated so you're
sweating and urinating more than you
normally would and then when you
actually cut back on the water at you
you kind of still flush out for a little
while afterwards so it's kind of like
just a manipulation that you're dizzy
you tricking your body into pissing more
so you lose more weight more water
weight in the last couple days pretty
much it's pretty much exactly figured
that out yeah like and just water in
general you know people people don't
drink enough water so when you're trying
to lose weight it's it's one of the best
things you can do for yourself but I
don't recommend - yawns for the ass -
gets a little much what's the most you
put back on a day three yawns put weight
you put back on I thought you man what's
the most weight you put back on dude
three gallons on one day I've done
through yellen's water and I used to do
that I try to refinish one no right
that's for mom I don't think she's ever
had a bottle of water in her life if
it's not coffee or soda I don't think
she's uh we I like something I like I
like some flavor in my beverage I like
something sweet yeah you know it's
definitely I think how most people are
like that luckily it's not a not a
problem for me for weight probably back
when we could IV I used to get up till I
181 from 155 that and that's just in 24
hours you put on 25 pounds 26 constant
day yeah and those guys that are still
doing that probably without IVs honestly
how do you obviously with an IV that
helps but we got an IV it's a little
harder without the eye because you got
to slowly make
you know if you just chug everything too
fast and you overdo it when you're
bodies that you know deplete it and
sucked out you're gonna you're gonna
just crap yourself or throw up yeah
that's the whole thing yeah guys put on
that much [ __ ] I'm always fascinated
by the way Carta and that with the
nightmare people have to go through the
week of the day before yeah and then all
that's fine right now what a Tuesday
we're I'm still eating good and you know
not I mean I wouldn't say good I'm
eating and you know I hired George
Lockhart so he's those guys are like a
little team of ninjas man everywhere you
turn or like here's your meal here's her
gallon of water so uh it's a bit of big
help for me this camp I just I can do
this stuff and not have to worry about
anything this is a big fight you know
I'm fighting in Brooklyn and I like
white now hello I want to be obviously
everything on my ducks in a row for this
one well what if you give me 155 what do
you weigh right now not 150 okay you're
good yeah yeah you're good so you have
to lose more than 10 pounds yeah yeah
yeah yeah but you guys don't like to say
exactly what you weigh leading I don't
want anybody out there knocking on my
door like that but it's not it's
definitely not
I know we've heard well we have a scale
under your chair right okay 238 this is
gonna be a hell of a it's gonna be a
rough week yeah put it that way how
[ __ ] up is it poor Tony Ferguson the
main event him against khabib and he's
on a stage doing his press is his last
day of his mandatory press yeah and I
guess he wears sunglasses indoors and I
really wonder if it had anything to do
with it there's a wire or something he
tripped over going to speak to somebody
he had didn't know was there and he
[ __ ] just tears oh tears ACL
yeah is that way I don't know if it was
it was one of the ligaments that it was
LCL maybe MCL
there's so many seals in the NIA I don't
really know which one it was but yeah he
tore a ligament tripping over a wire
yeah just it was like tree I see turn
away and then we find out about all this
on April Fool's Day so nobody believes
it when we all find out what it's like
people were all my friends were texting
me they're like this has got to be a
joke right
Tony Ferguson's I was like ah Dana's
playing a joke she's playing a joke and
then I texted my manager who's Max's
manager as well and he was like I swear
to god man it's actually I still didn't
believe it
all right well maybe they were sworn to
secrecy by Dana sounds like a long way
to go for a name I know that's what I
started thinking I was on a group text
with our you are unfiltered producer
with Kristin with Matt Serra so Chris
Texas oh yeah he's out and I think I
wrote like [ __ ] you and Matt like boom
April Fool and then when Dana's video he
goes uh it was uh this is not an April
Fool like oh no nobody started April
Fool's saying it's not yeah you can't
write everything when you're in training
do you are you kind of conscious of that
like I have to go hard enough that I'm
ready for this fight but not so more so
like I can't risk getting injured at all
it's that's where it's that's why so
many guys do get hurt right he's you
when you're when you're when you're
really sparring when we're actually
chucking throwing down and we got the
headgear Imangi it's usually not even
your sparring partner the guy in front
of that ends up hurting you it's some
weird thing like let's say you guys are
sparring over here my opponents here and
a guy comes flying in one for a double
leg and as the other guys getting taken
down hits my knee from the side all
those my knee it's usually something
like that or as I'm going down my ankle
gets stuck in the crease of the mat or
your toe gets stuck and it breaks it's
always some enough nothing that you
totally impaired yeah that's not usually
and you you know a lot of times I notice
I get hurt or banged up is when I'm
trying to go easy because you then
you're not doing the things you normally
do or go the way that you would normally
go so the other day I was even drilling
before I left Milwaukee and they're like
go easy I was like you know what [ __ ]
that and I was like let's let's just
drill hard and realistically and we'll
be safe and we were because when you're
trying to pull back is when you you do
something that's good move a certain way
that you're not used to moving [ __ ]
yourself up you're not in the flow of
how that that situation would really go
but who gets hurt doing press like
that's it man that you wear your
sunglasses inside man yes I wonder
that's why he tripped over a wire stones
can be dark he said he was wearing his
sunglasses so I mean I probably would've
left that detail out that's exactly what
I said when I heard that I was like I
probably would have just said 9
I wasn't of course I wasn't was it a
wire that he tripped over was that
exactly what it was I'm not even sure I
mean it's just totally to tear a
ligament though when you trip over
something you have to be like such an
athletic person I'm here to be walking
with purpose I don't think I could tear
a ligament walk hard man tripping over
something if I tried unless you fell off
a stage you might have felt you might
have fell off like a little riser oh I
am sometimes the TV studio has like a
little you're on a little platform what
I heard he he saw somebody that he
wasn't expecting to see and turn to say
hi and then tripped is what I heard oh
it's that person's fault
yeah I'm think they should be
responsible so if you if you're training
like you were saying right and you're
lying and somebody knocks into you and
causes you to get injured how long does
it take for that person did not be in
the doghouse yeah because I mean
theoretically it's an accident of course
yeah but realistically you just cost
everybody a whole bunch of money I guess
for me it would depend on were they
being in an absolute idiot or was it a
real accident like was there just a you
know a scenario where we bumped into
each other and it was nobody's fault but
there's some guys in the gym that are
known to be a little reckless or you
know crazy so if that guy hurts me then
yeah he's in he's in the doghouse for a
while with me because this is you know
this is real money that we're making and
that's how I make money is how I pay for
everything that I do so if I don't show
up to my fight because you were being an
idiot in the gym then I'll be pissed but
you don't anything if the other guy
doesn't show up be like there's no
compensation let's say something
happened to one of us this week like it
Tony yeah I mean there's I didn't make
way and I don't get my show money or
anything like that and nothing if how
about if I if your opponent doesn't make
weight do you still get some money if we
both show up and if I make weight and Al
doesn't make weight for some you know
let's just put that in the circle yeah I
get paid at least my show money okay
even if you decide not to fight him mmm
that's where it might get tricky if if
if the fight could be sanctioned and
still put on they might not be like Dana
might be like no the fight could go on
you're just choosing not to fight but
you know I'd fight so it's but if they
say no he there's no way you can fight
like I say okay if the Commission says
this fights off but I made 155 the UFC
would pay me they're good for that and
are you guys paying for your
training camps anything any expenses you
know that's why most of these guys that
aren't an LLC or some kind of corporate
tax write-off you know anything I need I
I make sure that it's through my my you
know my my business Paul Felder right
LLC so but like if you get injured yeah
your weight the end up in training yeah
that's why you just spent all that money
on the training camp oh yeah I get upset
if it's something stupid in the gym
where you like the guy threw a flying
knee and shattered your nose it's like
what do you do why we at the end of the
day yeah we need to train hard to get
ready for these fights but you need to
make it to the fight night yeah we're
professional fighters it's not like
we're doing this you know and some bar
drunkenly just because we want to get
our our you know aggression out we're
right for athletes and fighters so are
you more or less likely if you're in
public and someone gives you a problem
are you more or less likely to be
aggressive with them at this because I'm
such a little dick I know that I would
use it for bed yeah it didn't in my life
I can I can honestly say I would I would
man it depends on how many Jameson's
wearing me but if I was relatively
clear-headed I would I would avoid it
man like I've done enough in my fighting
career to know that I can I can whoop
irregular dudes ass I don't need to to
go to jail for it but back in college
you know that had been a different story
when I was still trying to prove myself
I pray I was an actor too back then so
if somebody stepped to me I'd I
definitely had a chip on my shoulder
back then because I was still a martial
artist and a fighter but I was also an
actor so it's like are you a good actor
I think so but what did you do what were
you doing you're doing that Bob I
theater I did theater yeah I went to
school you know when I went to school at
university arts in Philly it was I mean
it was a full-blown theater program that
I that I went to and was that in your
head were you like this is what I'm
gonna do with my life or did you kind of
know yeah I thought I was going to be an
actor I thought I was going to
transition to television film and and
and go that route eventually but I
wanted to get the training in and get
the experience and I mean there's live
theater is uh it's amazing man it's been
fighting is a very similar thing just on
a I mean a whole nother in the moment
level you know what I mean but very
similar feeling that you know that
stager in the locker room you're about
to go out there in front of people so
did you ever suck doing a play yeah I
was like don't plays that have sucked
you know what I mean so it there's been
somewhere it was like I've got bad
reviews yeah but did it bother you that
guys seemed like a decent critic critics
on Twitter talking about fighting it's
the same thing if somebody's like ah
fella but he's overrated thank you what
are you talking about no who I am you
don't know yeah yeah it's just the same
exact thing anybody's anything comedy
you know acting fighting anytime anybody
criticizes some guys are good at letting
it roll off all those are I'm not the
best to let in a roll well your I was
reading that there your fight people are
already saying like this could be fight
of the night right no yeah cuz now
expectations are up here so even if you
have an okay fight yeah people are gonna
go like I expect it better for them
these guys they didn't really go for it
anytime both our orbitals are broken
neither one of us have a hand that's not
broken but sometimes two guys respect
each other a lot and the first rather
kind of feeling each other out and
nobody wants to make a mistake is both
guys each one knows they can get knocked
out and [ __ ] up this is that fight Harry
give me an LBO they're being careful
it's also the great thing about Twitter
especially with the UFC is that like you
guys have spent your whole lives kind of
mastering this craft and then I can just
jump on Twitter after watching three
fights and be like you're not even
hitting each other yeah that goes for
anything right I mean yeah I can listen
to a show and go on Twitter me like man
that absolutely suck these guys don't
know what they're talking about and you
know they're not funny at all right you
know please we hear that every day right
same as we hear are you suck bro or al
is gonna knock your face off on my say
night I try to tweet at most of these
people nicely and retweet their tweets
when they say negative things about me I
found that that is the best you reach me
negative all of them anytime anybody's
cuz then my fans go ham on them they
just attack everybody and I don't have
to do anything right and it's just it's
funny to me it's like look I recognized
that you said something negative and I
don't I'm showing that I don't care but
I'm gonna let you guys care a little bit
yeah you want to see somebody else
attacked I want to see you I want to see
my fan
the Irish dragon fans uh get in there
did you go up in a rough area
Philadelphia again we've talked about
this performance Philadelphia's a very
rough area and there's a lot of for some
reason a lot of fighters come from
Philly boxers
yeah UFC guys that people who can fill
it up he just like to fight yeah I grew
up in a neighborhood grace Ferry and
it's it's definitely not a nice area I
when I was really little it wasn't so
bad there was still some you know
baseball programs and sports programs
and I got older and over you know people
were moving out and abandoning the
neighborhood drugs got really bad heroin
started getting really bad in that area
and luckily when I was a junior in high
school my family was able to move out of
there but up until that point you know
the years that count at the fight and
years the scrapping on the street yeah
there was a lot of it we just like I
talked about before when we when I was
on the show with you we uh we would
fight over anything man I was just fist
fight would break out that wasn't like a
big deal to me and now it's like God did
kids these days you get punched and it's
like you know that person should be
locked up for the rest of their life for
it so when you were when you were trying
to act in college were you trying to
like find something that was gonna get
you out of that neighborhood out of that
way of life out of all that yeah
honestly I was just trying to figure out
what the hell I was gonna do man cuz
I've never been super book-smart I've
never been really great at writing
papers or taking tests so if I was going
to go to college it definitely wasn't
gonna be for a degree in anything that
had to do with really really sitting
down and studying and it's not that I
don't have intelligence it's just I
could give a crap about sitting down in
front of a book and studying and writing
a paper on anything I had I've always
been very active in my learning so what
acting was like when I switched high
schools I just decided to take an acting
class and that was you know I literally
as they say I got bit by the bug and I
never wanted to stop doing that and I
had always done martial arts so that was
still something I had always planned on
doing whether it was through acting or
getting into martial arts movies or you
know owning my own school or something
like that but yeah that was me trying to
figure something out to do with my life
I didn't know what I was going to do
are you still acting or no not I mean I
just doing the the color commentary now
which is the next best thing for me
right now just because I'm still
currently fighting I don't really have
that much time to take off and and try
to pursue an acting career but it's
definitely something that I do want to
get back to when uh when I hang them up
man I want to try to really get out
there and and get an agent again but I
still want to do the the UFC and yeah
and do color work I love doing that and
that's just a fun way to make money in
between fights right now how much prep
do they give you for that like what
you're doing I'm always fascinated with
how everybody remembers how many fights
like the memories that you guys have
when you're when you're announcing are
they just you have a computer screen in
front of you or they they feed us a lot
of the producers are really good at
giving you stuff if they think it's
really important and then on top of that
the research teams and then and all the
guys that do UFC men we have just stats
that's sent to us I get emails I'm still
getting emails for for this fight I'm
getting I get emails every day for 223
about you know me and all these guys on
the card it's funny too
to open my email and it's like Paul
Felder's bio on yeah that was a very
sweet boy question or like do you just
remember everything wrong I mean how
much do they have to feed you certain
amount of things but I mean as far as my
job being the actual color go some notes
and I have to do it I have to do a lot
more actual just watching their fights
because I all the keys to the victory or
the highlights that are usually picked
out to show what they're good that's all
me like they'll tell me I need you to
look up Tony Ferguson it could be and
pick three things that could be does
really well no okay what's Tony gonna do
really well and I have to go and pick
those highlights so that's really where
my job gets interesting and in-depth as
far as that but as far as the stats we
get a ton of really good research sent
to us from the UFC what do you what do
you think of comedians max Holloway
who's the featherweight champion who's
stepping up to fight but I mean he's
obviously heavier because he's not you
know he's not having a cut way out one
what he walks around it heavy he does
right yeah I read 180 so I'm not
twisting 182 is that true this what max
box around enough I can't confirm that
but I know that I just based on the eye
test I know max is it no I don't know
about right now but I know that in past
he's gotten up over 180 just he's a
thick Hawaiian kid man so will he be
able to get down to that way I think
he's I saw him last night he was on the
treadmill it was actually me could be a
max and the whole Dagestan the army yeah
in the workout room last night and he
was on there for an hour and he has he
was in high spirits afterwards and I
know he's working with with George and
the guys and I know they had him fast
as soon as they got the fight started
24-hour fast try to get in the you know
ketosis get him fat-burning and um I
think I think he will make it I think
he's a he's tough enough and he does big
enough cuts 245 so right he's got the
weight to lose at least at 5500 that's
right he's yesterday I hit 45 or so he's
losing 10 less penalties it's gonna be
tough so they were working out in the
same room at the same time he's not
almost a treadmill apart from each other
are they like snarling at each other
like her now you know at this point man
I think it's uh
and I think khabib respects him for what
he did so I think he wants to smash him
on Saturday night I think at the same
time he's like man all right hey way to
step up and save the day and come in and
take this money nobody not he wants
anyway and I take it on short notice so
yeah nobody really wants to fight we had
him on yesterday Kirby he seems very
very confident in his ability to win
this fight yeah of course yeah I
couldn't see why anybody would want to
fight that man he really light him too
and you got to fight the whole team of
guys that are surrounding him 24 hours a
day I wouldn't I couldn't even get on
the treadmill yesterday for for 10
minutes because his team was on their
way and they're all really nice so he's
got a lot of guys with him yeah now were
you naturally good at fighting like when
you started fighting as a kid and just
yeah I don't mean like professional I
mean like just getting into fights were
you losing or were you winning them I
want a lot of fights when I was a kid I
was crazy you know what I mean I was the
the redheaded kid that got picked on so
I learned to throw down from from a
young age my brother Tommy me and him
used to box with winter mittens on that
was our he said will you
you can go bare and alcohol wear winter
gloves that was the padding's weed box
and we played like knee football is
anybody ever play no ball
played other knee games but they were
less pleasant yeah we uh what brought
you here the tape effective I'll have a
ball field on our carpet you know at
home and we had a football and there was
an end zone on either end and you had to
stay on your knees and try to get past
each other and if you went down you went
down him we got in a lot of fights over
this was it just it was it just touch no
it was smashing I'm four years younger
so I play touch me now now I'm the
bigger brother but what does he do now
Tommy
yeah he's hitting between stuff right
now he used to work for septa which is
like the public transportation unit and
you know and that was what my dad worked
for my brother younger brother John
works Receptus so but then I fight you
know those guys train or fight no no I
could never I could never get anybody to
do it I always wanted you know one of my
brothers to jump on it with me I feel
like I almost convinced my older brother
a couple times to come and start doing
jujitsu I don't think it's too late I
think we can still rope him in and get
him training a little bit just keep him
keep him busy you know he could scrap he
can definitely fight but for a guy that
can scrap on the street you know what I
mean he just got a big haymaker Cobra
hands being a redheaded kid in Philly
now it was a racially diverse
neighborhood was it a white hooded split
up yeah I mean that was part of the
problem is you definitely had your your
your units right you had the Irish
writing that right near my you know the
Catholic Church that I grew up literally
across the street from if I looked out
my window I'm looking at the school that
I went to when I was in grade school and
then you know the projects were right
there and then there was you know like
an Italian section and you know you know
Puerto Rican and a Hispanic section so
we people battled man there was oh
especially you know unfortunately the
black and white going at it sure in that
neighborhood and nervous there was news
reports on it kids getting killed and
shot in pharmacies and stuff when I was
really little like that went to school
with my older brother and for no reason
and yeah we were on the news quite a bit
you know at least local news in Philly
for for being a really racial tense
neighborhood but are you carry a weapon
with you what's that did you carry a
weapon with you no no I mean
just his hand yeah it's just uh I mean
luckily especially then I nothing like
that I've never had a gun drawn on me or
anything like that but I've definitely
gotten jumped and and I'm into
fistfights and stuff like that have you
thought about how long you want to fight
for now that you've got like you've
you're good at announcing and you like
announcing so there's that you know
you've got acting that you still want to
do so there's that you know there are
other things beyond this fighting world
have you thought about how long oh yeah
you want to do this yeah I'll be 34 this
month but I'm happy yes I'm a pretty
young 34 in the sport just because I
didn't turn pro until I was in my late
20s so it's not like I've been doing
this some of these guys since I was 16
yeah turning pro well that's a lot of
damage you had I would say three or four
years and we'll see we'll see where I'm
at if I'm champion and I'm fighting for
the belt or I'm in the top five I stay
around if if if I'm ever starting to get
called a gatekeeper come on yeah yeah
didn't who do so tyron woodley just said
that about wonderboy called him a
gatekeeper because he's fighting Darren
to us I guess that was meant as an
insult yeah and he meant it as an insult
but to Wonderboys defense I mean when
you're when you're at that level and
only losing to a guy like Tyron that I
wouldn't retire either I mean that
that's not what I'm talking about I'm
talking about it went on the guy that's
being fed the up-and-coming guy just
because I mean I know till is but I
think they honestly want to see what's
gonna have play out where till and
Thompson but I don't want to name names
but there's certain guys we know in
divisions that it's like yeah he's still
a name he's sure enough but he's
probably never gonna be in the in the
top ten again if I'm ever that guy and
I'm just fighting to fight I can do
other things
how'd he do commentating I can try
acting again what do you think of what
Ronda Rousey is doing leaving UFC and
going over to w e hey yeah I mean she's
making good money she's having fun it's
something different
she's got the personality people want to
see it I have no problem with her doing
that does that sheet get in your head
like I watched the women like whatever
Connor fights he gets into people's
heads I think he got into Josie alders
head really badly at the talking
oh man the Eddie Alvarez I was at the
fight you could see that it caught the
moment God was a big moment Nate Diaz
you could [ __ ] it you could hit about
the piano it doesn't bother but those
guys you can't get in through his head
no he's but he's a [ __ ] he's an
animal and he's just puts his middle
finger in your feint it doesn't bother
him right Hammond you can't intimidate
him so I think that's why those fights
go differently does that stuff bother
you at all one guys talk trash and all
that but is there a level of it that
does get to you yeah eventually just to
me it gets annoying because I grew up a
very traditional martial arts background
to me it's Minh it's a fight game so I
mean the respect it has to be there to a
degree but you know trash talk is kind
of encouraged it's okay it's a show we
got to sell paper reviews I get that but
the way I was brought up you know you
just it's about competition it's about
me just beating your ass and being
better than you and then I have no
problem with you afterwards so that's
where it's it kind of gets on my nerves
a little bit but when guys do it to me
it's a it doesn't bother me in the way
that if I like you I'm gonna knock you
out I'm trying to knock you out either
way if I don't like you I'm gonna try to
knock you out and finish your night I
like Stevie Ray I really like that guy I
was glad that he got reassigned I was
kind of upset that I had to fight him
because I was like if I beat this guy
he's losing in front of all so I kind of
felt bad that that that scenario was on
the table it didn't stop me from being
him in the face and hit him with elbows
it is easy to do to someone that you
even look there's certain guys like I
would never fight this guy like Dana
said him and DC would never fight right
but you don't get you'll fight pretty
much is there anybody you wouldn't fight
Anthony Pettis he's my teammate right
now we train together you know we're in
the grind every day together we're in
the sauna for this camp together and I
feel like there's no need based on where
our careers are and I feel like there's
enough guys in the division that we
could clear out that we wouldn't have to
face each other right now
other than that no but if you had to you
would do it man it would have to be a
crazy I don't know what I would do we
are in the same team so I would have to
I would have to try to figure something
else out and turn it down or because I'm
not leaving that team I feel like that's
what changed my career working with Duke
Rufus and the guys at
at Rufus sports oh yeah III I couldn't
do that fight and I think the UFC knows
that how does the coach decide who
decide cuz I think that they would have
to honestly they would have to side with
Anthony they'd have to go with Anthony
and I wouldn't expect them not to if
he's been went longer he's been there
forever he's he's the reason that Jim
and Duke would say the same thing that
that Jim I mean Duke obviously has all
his credentials and he was a stud
kickboxer at heavyweight but what made
them even bigger was obviously the
Showtime and Anthony and becoming the
champ so I would never expect them in
the back or an answer
yeah what about CM Punk E transer yeah
how's he doing he's doing so much better
man he's he really has gotten better
since that fight with with Mick Eagle
and he trains hard man I think it's one
of those tricky situations because
everybody wants to be so negative on him
and and even early on when I before I
knew him I was like all geez what's
going on here with the WWE guy coming in
but once I got to know him you know I
can't hate I can't hate him he got the
opportunity and he's just taking
advantage of it and if they're gonna
give him fights go for it man he's gonna
be successful in June I do yeah have
they announced who he's fighting even
now I don't think they have how they not
that I've heard no I don't think it's
official yet but I yeah I know there's
rumors that it's gonna be that that guy
I think that lost to um make you gone
his debut when they when they fought in
the UFC to see who was gonna possibly
fight oh okay that's a rumor I know I
don't know if that's official but if
that's the case I hundred percent think
he's gonna win that fight for him do you
get annoyed
during media days because you have to
talk to us for like a half hour and
that's like a half hour of water that's
not getting drank yeah but you gallons
is like you're sitting there like huh
like it's an hours gone by you've been
talking and you're looking at that thing
it's still half full like what the [ __ ]
am I gonna do today yeah well once I
start working out later on after this is
all done that water will start coming
out I want more of it yeah it's funny by
the time you're done with the the two
gallons and the loading and stuff you
start in
start narrowing it down to maybe a
gallon or less you're like I don't have
enough water cuz you get so used to just
if you start getting thirsty it's the
weirdest thing in the world that yeah
and then by the time you cut on Thursday
you're like remember when I was
complaining about all that water she
should have smacked me when I was
complaining about drinking the water cuz
then you want it pretty bad
you have to [ __ ] right before you walked
out that's always something I think of
like yeah I know I'd have to [ __ ] right
before I walked out yeah I've had to
like run in the bathroom I mean not not
right before I walked out but definitely
in the back I've never seen anybody have
to leave the cage to do what would they
do the [ __ ] [ __ ] Chris Chris Weidman
I think's got a story work he like had
bubble guts like he thought he was gonna
crap his pants on the way to uh ah man I
can't remember what fight he's got a
pretty funny story about it but yeah he
was his stomach was not right after the
weight cut and he talks about that
saying there's a few guys that have some
pretty good stories about they're
definitely people who shat in the
Octagon well you lose the fight
automatically now the person lose the
fight yeah let him roll in there oh but
what did he run back in the bathroom I
know I I think he had time to do it but
I think he still had to go on his way
out to the yeah so what if you're there
and you have to [ __ ] you just have to go
through it or you either will they let
you run back to I guess if you said hey
I'm going to the bathroom what are they
gonna do what have you just reached over
to the referee and said I have to yeah
that would be in between rounds you know
they say so are you ready sir you ready
if one guy was just like you know what
hold on I need I need to go I need I
need to talk to my fax let me can I talk
to my coaches oh yeah I have to make
time to pee I'm always fascinated to
when guys will fight 30 seconds ever
getting kicked in the dick like it
happens once in a while you can tell
it's an accident but I guess what's the
best thing for that they say to squat or
to sit on your cup there's like some
weird thing they said you guys tell you
to like sit on your butt and and and
like balance yourself all the guys kind
of jump and stomp to get everything to
settle back down sometimes it can happen
where one of your testicles actually
gets like knocked up in
cavity you know where your you worry you
know where things sure the opening
that's one of the one of the I won't say
who it is one of the guys who hosts the
UFC podcast has a trick to get that down
with his mouth doesn't matter but yeah
I'm the most amazing guys about fighting
30 seconds are they getting kicked in
the balls I take the full five yeah I
think it actually affected one of my my
really good friends Jared Gordon who
fought I guess a month or two ago or
less than a month or two ago Diego Fiera
kicked him and he you know he being in
the moment he wanted to come right back
he wanted to come right back and that he
got rocked right after that and you know
unfortunately took his first loss in the
UFC you know I remember talking to him
afterwards just recent he's been
training with us this week to he lives
in in Queens and I was like man I think
part of it was you weren't quite all
there yet you know what I mean
you took a good shot to two in a row and
then the second one he's like nah let's
just you know are I'm ready and
sometimes you're not